I feel like the first time ever I'm
focusing on me it's crazy I never in my
life would have thought that like I
would have had a lot in common with the
Russian Nikki Bella dropped some serious
bombs on the season finale of total
Bella's first she confirmed her
relationship with Artem then girl rides
off into the sunset with him I'm ready
to really explore new things and people
and just really see what certain
chemistry's are all about Nikki has
officially moved on our demand Nikki
we're partners on Dancing with the Stars
back in 2017 they clearly had a strong
bond
even back then check this out we spend a
lot of time together and they need a lot
from us and so I'm someone who when that
happens I kind of shut down but Artem
knows how to break through me and he's
really like learned how to like let my
guard down and so I use like my Russian
therapist it's great but now things have
turned romantic oh yeah and a lot can
change in just a few months because back
in September Nikki told ET she was not
looking for love I have to man I mean I
am single but I'm I'm not ready for
mingling yet you know I I don't know we
see a lot of that healing process in
this final episode Nikki admits she's
still grieving her breakup with
ex-fiance John Cena and she takes a big
step by going to Napa Valley the last
time she was there was nearly a year ago
to check out wedding venues and there's
a moment where Nikki and her twin sister
Bree have that conversation about John I
think that's why I was crying so justr I
feel like it was like this first
I'm like I'm holy like was starting my
true like grieving healing process are
you gonna be okay if all sitting in a
couple weeks if he's like seeing with a
girl no matter what the next time I see
him with someone it's gonna kill me I
still have a long way to go but honestly
I'm ready for a new me and that's all a
natural part of the process but Nikki
and Artem's relationship has been
budding for a few months now it was back
in January their flirtation started
heating up on the show the last time I
saw our time I was in a relationship for
so long so I'm just really excited to
see them today you know what we love la
than we love celebrating it so cheers to
Nikki and Artem we're gonna keep you
guys updated on the latest on this
budding romance until next time I'm ash
Carlton and I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now